heads up guys my name is Jenna welcome
to another Sparky dev vlog this develop
number six so this is gonna be a short
one because I'm extremely busy and
working on Sparky I'm extremely busy and
I've just had a very busy week and
everything is kind of broken right now
because what I'm doing right now and
this is really what a dev vlog is about
right I'm trying to update you guys on
what I'm doing and this is not always
something to show unfortunately but I'm
actually putting in direct3d into Sparky
okay
so currently Sparky's renderer only
supports OpenGL
I wanted to support both directx and
opengl the reason I'm doing that is
because DirectX is just better to use on
Windows the second reason is the API is
just beautiful and miles better than
opengl 3 I'm interested to see what the
performance characteristics will be in
Sparky compared to OpenGL and also it is
much better to design tools that use
direct3d even
OpenGL okay so for example if I'm using
WPF to build a level editor DirectX
integrates with like a Windows
application like embedded in a Windows
application a hundred times better than
OpenGL there are very big problems with
embedding OpenGL into into a WPF
application so that being said that's
why I'm doing it so to kind of prove my
point and to actually get something
working I constructed a small demo which
is actually pretty large like I mean
there are like 50 files Lamas in this
solution in this project and it's kind
of almost like Sparky but it's
completely standalone it doesn't really
use spike the only section of Sparky
that uses the math library it's kind of
use the same API right I've clearly
separate a system uniform system
uniforms from user uniforms as like hold
on more user forms which basically like
material uniforms
you can specify buffalo asked the same
way you can in Sparky you construct
vertex buffers in it and index buffers
the same way you do in Sparky you can
set uniform buffers and buy materials as
you can see the same way that you do in
Sparky the shaders of
[ __ ] are different so this is like
what the hlsl shader for this little
test of mine looks like right and that's
written in a cell of course and not GLSL
and then there's that shade of being set
here but if we launch this quickly and
it's nothing special it's just a kind of
there's a color there's uniform color
here and there are two textures being
blended together and an updating uniform
which is the model matrix and you can
see kind of how that works so it's just
a little demo it basically covered
everything the one thing this is missing
or the two things that's missing are
cube maps and frame buffers right so
rendering two textures is something that
I have to put into this little demo and
then I'm ready to take this demo and put
it into Sparky and and wire everything
up and I was actually going to make a
video or in this video even I was going
to try you guys a diagram of how the the
architecture for supporting to rendering
api's was going to work in Sparky
because it's a very difficult topic when
you want to support to rendering api's
especially when there is debt they are
as different as you know direct3d and
OpenGL which operate quite differently
right I mean I have to say I prefer the
I prefer to write X but they you know I
I prefer DirectX API wise the API is
beautiful at least it is for DirectX 11
I should be saying direct3d 11 but
anyway when I say DirectX I really mean
to ready because we're all talking about
graphics here and particularly 3d
graphics okay so that being said though
hooking up to API is very difficult
especially doing it in a way that is
actually good right and my vision for
Sparky is you should be able to
basically choose the API at runtime it
shouldn't be a compile time decision
right unless of course if you're on Mac
and Linux it's gonna have to be a
compile time decision because that's not
going to be able to compile any direct3d
code but the point is it has to be a
runtime decision and then you have to
basically end up creating a layer of
abstraction you have to choose a point
at which you kind of start making API
independent code in your engine and you
have to hook everything up properly and
you
have to make sure that you set up proper
interfaces and proper implementations of
everything in it it is a bit of a
nightmare it's very difficult to set up
so I was gonna draw you guys the
architecture for it but I can't find my
like graphics tablet so that's
unfortunate but I when I do I'll
probably make a video detailing how that
works and I'll probably put it in first
and then I might make a video anyway
that's what you see in this demo it's
free it's pretty simple and it
demonstrates pretty much every every
part of DirectX that I need to put into
Sparky and the actual like you know the
actual code of course is just in these
files here like for example loading a
shader and DirectX happens right here
you know textures a big one texture two
days you know happen here it's all in
all it's a very easy API to use okay
cool
that is the first thing that that's the
big thing that I'm working on so there's
not much to show unfortunately for that
except for that demo and I've also done
significant refactoring and Sparky on a
different branch to this to this one
which actually would show all new me
creating interfaces and moving a lot of
code and Sparky around to an API
independent kind of layer right because
there has to be that independence layer
that that independent layer that the
rest of the engine uses and then of
course behind that abstraction is are
the actual implementations of each
feature like a vertex buffer an index
buffer a texture for each API creating
that also means I can add future API so
I can add Vulcan for example which I'm
planning to do in the distant future
when I feel like it
the Vulcans API is kind of similar to
OpenGL so it's not very good but I
probably will out that eventually and
even maybe matte although I don't
imagine metal will happen anytime soon
Volken though is probably gonna be the
next one after direct3d 11 but that
won't happened for a while okay cool
anyway all that aside PPR wise I don't
think much has changed I did on the
other branch I was on I did cry did make
materials be PBR materials and I did see
touch change around a significant amount
of things because there are there are
things in the code that don't work with
direct3d and that actually are wrong
basically cuz if you look at something
like layer 2d you'll see that I'm
setting you know the
uniform textures why is that happening
here right why is this projection matrix
being set here it's just it's all weird
and directx kind of forces me to clean
that stuff up because it's very strict
about how you do things which is good
because basically you know when you're
writing an engine that supports both you
almost want to just make OpenGL work
like DirectX because that is that is the
correct way pretty much or as far as my
opinion goes anyway okay but I do have
this just for fun I do have this nice
kind of asset that I imported someone
suggested that I actually get some
assets online instead of using cubes and
planes with textures that I created
myself so I got this PBR dagger if you
just google it you can get it
this is rented in marmoset which is a
little PBR kind of viewing thing it's
it's quite nice it's um mum said tool
bag would be the appropriate the actual
application which is good for like kind
of authoring pv ices as well you can
take a look at that this is what it
looks like they provide a lot of maps a
lot of maps that I don't support so they
provide this asset includes like cavity
maps and AO maps which I don't support
just yet ambient occlusion maps but so I
kind of did with what I could do but
this is what it looks like in Sparky
there's that dagger oh I need to not set
I had to not override the glass though
otherwise that's gonna look all funny
where is that dagger material here it is
um dagger I thought I wasn't hmm I am
alright no overriding boss so I'm using
the default textures that came with the
model and is what it was like I can't
even
fullscreen it for you let me just move
that cube out of the way cube goodbye
that's what it looks like I mean it
looks pretty it looks pretty different
than it doesn't the thing it looks kind
of alright the it looks like they're
glass curved though is a lot higher over
a lot more linear meaning that it's like
lower glass values Kendra
do more actual reflection looks like
obviously there's a bunch of
post-processing on this there is no
post-processing on this whatsoever but
you know it's that mean it's there like
if I had moved the light direction
around you can kind of see how that
reflects and changes the it doesn't look
too bad I think and of course we could
be also overriding the gloss manually
which is what I kind of put into the
debug menu as well to just make it
really lit really really shiny or
something like that which would look
kind of weird I think
but anyway cube can go away so here we
go gloss so you can see how we can kind
of override that gloss and make it
really I don't know what happens at low
gloss values I need to investigate that
just about some kind of boundary
condition all right if we kind of bring
that gloss up you can see how it becomes
really really reflective and you can
kind of see the until I keep my throat
as well so anyway that's kind of how
that works
that's kind of how that looks in my
engine and Sparky
looks interesting so yeah I just wanted
to chuck an actual asset and show you
guys what that looks like hopefully
again what I do implement I'm still I've
still got a few things for PBR that I
need to implement so ambient occlusion
Maps cavity maps to an extent I don't
even know if I will bother supporting
the but ambient occlusion maps do need
to get in as do emissive Maps as well
with your really easy to do so that's
what I'll do
but so far I'm kind of working on that
direct next thing and that's the way
it's going to go probably for another
week I'll shoot I should be done by next
day vlog hopefully thought you will
support both OpenGL and direct3d
completely fully 100% alright thanks for
watching guys hope you enjoyed this dev
vlog if you did please hit the like
button if you want to support Sparky and
get all these exclusive kind of copies
of it then you can support me on patreon
now if you pledge $5 or more you get
access to the version and repository
which basically contains all the code
that I type between
github comments right so I still commit
to github like at least once a month
pretty much but as for the code that's
on my computer that is basically on
committed you can get access to that if
you pledge $5 per month if you really
want you know new code every day
basically and you really want to keep
track of the development every day if
you don't of course
you mean Sparky's not never gonna cause
money it's not it's always free and open
source so you can just wait patiently
and it will be provided to you on
github.com four slash three or four
slash Sparky also you guys should join
my slack because slack is pretty cool
and I I'm usually on there a lot you can
say that people like talk about stuff
all the time and I've kind of been
almost trading this as like my personal
kind of dev vlog kind of blog things so
I post like photos to it all the time or
like screenshots of Sparky and all that
stuff so it's a really good place to
hang out and you can just join by
entering in your mail address here
alright anyway thanks for watching guys
I'll see you next ever log goodbye